[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
abend der juni ist da und mit ihm tank
rabatt und neun euro ticket beides teil
eines entlastungs paket der
bundesregierung mit dem die steigenden
belastungen der bürgerinnen und bürger
abgefedert werden sollen beide maßnahmen
sind schon im vorfeld heftig diskutiert
worden am düsteren prognosen mangelte es
nicht überfüllte züge und hohe stadt
sinkende spritpreise
doch siehe da am ersten tag lief es
alles in allem ziemlich rund über sinn
und unsinn der maßnahmen reden wir
gleich mit einem experten zuvor nicola
albrecht mit eindrücken aus brandenburg
vor dem angekündigten chaos und vollen
zügen im pendlerverkehr hat das ehepaar
denner keine angst in vorfreude auf
einen sommer voller bahn abenteuer in
brandenburg starten die rentner mit
ihren neuen euro tickets gleich heute
morgen um 8 uhr in cottbus hier sind
schon 25 jahre keine bahn angefangen und
wir werden das auf alle fälle jetzt die
drei monate nutzen
und damit sind sie nicht allein seit
verkaufsbeginn vergangenen freitag haben
hier täglich 1000 fahrgäste einen neuen
euro ticket gekauft was die örtlichen
verkehrsbetriebe allerdings nur bedingt
freut
es kann ein guter auftakt sein um den
menschen zu zeigen dass man sich auf den
öpnv verlassen kann dass man auf jeden
fall gut damit von a nach b kommt aber
das ganze muss eigentlich einhergehen
mit einem wirklich spürbaren
angebotsausbau die schwierigkeit für uns
besteht darin zum einen haben wir
natürlich auch eine begrenzte anzahl von
fahrzeugen die wir nicht von jetzt auf
gleich auf stoppen können wir haben auch
dann in spitzenzeiten mit einem gewissen
personalmangel zu kämpfen das liegt aber
auch daran dass wir natürlich auch
unsere mitarbeitenden urlaub haben und
den auch im sommer zu recht nehmen
wollen die angst an kapazitätsgrenzen zu
stoßen ist bei den überschaubaren
bahnverbindungen in den ländlichen
regionen brandenburgs noch viel größer
denn dort hat man sie vielerorts bereits
mit den regulären pendlern erreicht und
entsprechend skeptisch sehen die die
zusätzliche konkurrenz um einen
sitzplatz
wenn man einen zug ausfällt wie heute
dann wird es natürlich toll und dann
wären da noch fast komplett
abgeschnittene landkreise wie die
uckermark die prignitz und die ränder
des havellandes wo es zum teil gar keine
schienenverbindungen mehr gibt denn hier
wurden seit der wende mehr als 500
kilometer bahnstrecken stillgelegt und
busse fahren wenn überhaupt oft nur
zweimal am tag meistens leer auch heute
trotz neun euro ticket umso größer ist
hier der andrang an den tankstellen der
angekündigte rabatt wurde tatsächlich
vielerorts bereits umgesetzt 35 cent
weniger pro liter super dafür dieter
tanz vorsorglich gleich mal den ersatz
kanister und auch weißmüller wolter
macht sich erleichterung breit ich habe
jetzt echt lange immer nur stück für
stück getankt und jetzt heute mal
richtig genau aufs auto angewiesen ich
wohne in einem dorf und darf hätte bus
ganz selten das entlastungspaket mit
neun euro ticket und tank rabatt es
stieß bei vielen brandenburgern heute
erst einmal auf positive resonanz das
befürchtete chaos bei bus bahn und an
den tankstellen blieb aus doch auch
skepsis bleibt dass die effekte zu
schnell verpuffen und sich ein
flächenland wie brandenburg eben nicht
so schnell umbauen lässt
ja dass man euro ticket für den
bundesverkehrsminister volker wissing
ist da schon jetzt ein voller erfolg und
impuls für eine stärkung des
öffentlichen personennahverkehrs sehr
optimistisch klang er heute abend auch
bei uns bei zdf arte live ich habe mich
gefreut dass so viele menschen
begeistern mit begeisterung das neue
ticket kaufen und nutzen und ich hatte
vertrauen in die verkehrsunternehmen und
sehe mich bestätigt das hat gut
funktioniert es war sehr gut vorbereitet
und sehr gut organisiert und auch die
bahn meldet mir vor wenigen minuten dass
der tag erfolgreich verlaufen ist
so sieht das die politik schauen wir wie
die wissenschaft ist sieht professor
andreas knie ist mobilitäts forscher am
wissenschaftszentrum berlin für
sozialforschung und wir erreichen ihn in
gera schwingen abend
herr professor knie eine belebung im
besten fall für den öpnv das verspricht
sich ja der verkehrsminister auch und
das wäre mit blick auf die angestrebte
verkehrswende wünschenswert hat das 9
euro je kind aus ihrer sicht dazu
wirklich das zeug ja
natürlich noch nicht es ist ein erster
anfang der minister hat tatsächlich
recht der pnv ist wieder in aller munde
wir haben es eben im beitrag gehört
menschen die seit 20 jahren nicht mehr
bus und bahn genutzt haben fahren jetzt
also insofern hat das zur
popularisierung von bussen und bahnen
wirklich einen guten beitrag geleistet
denn wir dürfen nicht vergessen werden
die pandemie und viele sind busse und
bahnen fern geblieben dafür war dass
neun euro ticket jetzt wirklich prima so
und was kommt danach nach den drei
monaten
ja genau das ist jetzt die frage wir
glauben dass die menschen jetzt sehen
mit neun euro ist ja wunderbar zumal 9
euro überall gelten also ich kann den
brandfall ich kann aber auch in garmisch
partenkirchen fahren ich kann wie ich
jetzt gerade gera unterwegs sein mit
neun euro überall das gleiche und das so
denken wir uns das und so hoffen wir
dass auch dass die menschen sagen
wunderbar im nahverkehr es müsste jetzt
immer ganz einfach sein und dieser tarif
wird diese haben diese unüberwindbaren
hindernissen die ich nicht verstehen die
müssten verschwinden und wenn so was wie
ein einheitlicher preis für alles für
alle leistungen gelten könnte dann wäre
das ein wirklich erster schritt in die
verkehrswende aber müssen müssen wir
nochmal klar feststellen sie geben dem
jetzt in diesem in dieser drei monats
variante wenig chancen dass das einen
nachhaltigen effekt erzeugen könnte auch
wenn sieben millionen schon tickets
erworben haben
ja dafür ist die zeit einfach zu kurz
sind drei monate da hätte man sich
natürlich ein ganzes jahr wünschen
können und vor allen dingen viele
strecken der fernbahn sind überhaupt
nicht beteiligt das heißt wir haben nur
die nahverkehrszüge und natürlich sind
jetzt die berühmten schnäppchenjäger
erst mal unterwegs
die diese zeit nutzen und menschen die
bisher im auto saßen die bleiben auch
leider auch nach den drei monaten wieder
im auto aber wir glauben dass das so
viel begeisterung auslöst dass die
menschen sagen hey drei monate ist um um
aber ich würde jetzt gerne wieder
einfach und einheitlich die im öpnv
unterwegs sind und dann hätten wir
vielleicht ein effekt dass der öpnv
danach ein anderer würde als er vorher
war und dafür müsst ihr natürlich auch
alles funktionieren jetzt hört man dass
pfingsten ein ziemlicher stress test
werden könnte was erwarten sie wird die
bahn da in die knie gehen selbst
ehemalige bahn verantwortliche äußern
sich der heute ziemlich skeptisch
ja das ist wieder eine typisch deutsche
diskussion sofort wieder das problem zu
sehen wir freuen uns doch erstmal dass
die leute jetzt begeistert fahren und
dann wird natürlich mal die eine oder
andere bahn wirklich voll sein die bei
uns vorher auch schon voll dann wird man
den anderen zug nehmen hauptsache man
hat jetzt wieder lust auf das produkt
bahn und bus das ist entscheidend und
dann kann auch der eine andere bahnhof
mal voller sein die eine oder andere zug
mal voller sein das werden wir schon
alles schaffen schauen wir noch mal auf
den tank rabatt und die frage wie passt
das eine mit dem anderen zusammen das
funktionierte heute relativ gut die
preise gingen runter was gerade für
menschen die aufs auto angewiesen sind
wirklich ein segen es aber im grunde
kontraproduktiv zum neuen euro ticket
oder
genau das ist das eigentliche problem
das ist nämlich kein wirklich
integrierter bestandteil einer
verkehrswende politik wir wissen alle
dass das auto nicht mehr so billig sein
kann es autofahren wird teurer wir haben
die pariser klima verträge
unterschrieben wir haben das den
beschluss des bundesverfassungsgerichts
urteil wir müssen teure preise im auto
haben das autofahren wird teurer eine
verbilligung ist völlig falsch die
privilegien des autos müssen
zurückgenommen werden und wir müssen
stattdessen natürlich dauerhaft den öpnv
stärken ihn ausbauen in attraktiv machen
und nicht mit strohfeuer aktivitäten
sozusagen den öpnv abspeisen und dann
sich dann doch wieder auf das auto
konzentrieren das hilft nicht der
mobilitäts forscher im heute-journal
dankeschön professor knie nach gera
im bundestag verteidigte kanzler olaf
scholz heute die entlastungsmaßnahmen
sie seien wirksam kämen direkt beim
bürger an und vom von nutzen sei niemand
ausgeschlossen der bundeskanzler
präsentierte sich heute in der
generaldebatte wieder einmal in der
entschlossenen und leidenschaftlichen
scholz variante die also die wir eher
selten sehen und das hat eher etwas mit
seinem vorredner zu tun friedrich merz
der oppositionsführer hatte die debatte
mit scharfen angriffen auf den kanzler
und seine ukraine politik eröffnet und
scholz wehrte sich aus berlin karl
hinterleitner
im bundestag geht es heute ums geld es
geht um ihn krieg und um die folgen für
das land cdu-chef märz eröffnet mit
einem frontalangriff gegen den kanzler
seit dessen verkündung der zeitenwende
vor rund drei monaten sehr schwammig und
vage olaf scholz rede viel und sage
nichts
sie haben an diesem tag gesagt die sie
die lage sehen seit dem fall dampft und
verdienste das alles was sie da gesagt
haben im unklaren im ungefähren und es
wird keine konkrete entscheidung
getroffen und hier begründet die an
dieses niveau und in diesen level
anschließt der sonst zugelassene kanzler
antwortet angriffslustig sich nicht
festzulegen die lieferung schwerer
waffen womöglich gar zu verschleppen all
das weist er geradezu kämpferisch zurück
alles was sie sagen ist nicht richtig
wir machen das was möglich ist was soll
denn andere schwere waffen seien als zb
gebhard oder die panzerhaubitze das ist
doch einfach
dahergeredet es zeigt dass sie nach
vortrag und dann kündigt olaf scholz
überraschend sogar noch neue
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine an zum
beispiel hat die bundesregierung aktuell
entschieden dass wir mit dem system iris
t das modernste flugabwehrsystem liefern
über das deutschland verfügt damit
versetzen die die ukraine in die lage
eine ganze großstadt vor russischen
luftangriffen zu schützen auch das ist
eine entscheidung die sache wird die
grünen an sich friedensbewegte machen
deutlich das sondervermögen für rüstung
jetzt aufzulegen sei richtig aber leicht
verletzt ihn nicht auch wir höher dann
manchmal auch wir wägen ab und ja
vielleicht könnten manche entscheidungen
auch schneller getroffen werden
aber wir stehen an der seite der ukraine
und sagen ja zum recht auf
selbstverteidigung
auch die traditionell gegen neue
schulden eingestellte fdp fügt sich in
die besondere situation meint aber die
finanzpolitik insgesamt bleibe dennoch
solide wir weichen nicht von der
schuldenbremse ab wir schleifen nicht
die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
sondern wir werden am freitag mit zwei
drittel mehrheit dieses sondervermögen
beschließen was speziell der bundeswehr
zur verfügung steht und vor allen dingen
herr kollege merz wer erhöhen nicht die
steuern die linke empört soziale belange
kamen zu kurz mehr geld fürs militär sei
falsch und ein irrweg dieses sommers ist
gegenüber den millionen menschen in
unserem land die existenzielle sorgen
und nöte haben einfach eine
unverschämtheit und die afg sieht das
land mehr oder weniger am abgrund so
ihre vorsitzende schuld an allem die
regierung
inflation energieknappheit
explodierender energiepreise
gestörte lieferketten fachkräftemangel
und überlastete sozialkassen sind die
folge politischer fehlentscheidungen
als der kanzler den saal verlässt hat er
viel kritik anhören müssen vor allem an
seiner kommunikation die aber zumindest
da heute eindeutig
ja und das hat ja echt nachrichtenwert
heute im bundestag deutschland liefert
der ukraine moderne abwehrsysteme
schauen wir uns das noch mal genauer an
dabei ist das luftabwehrsystem iris t
dieser raketen können in der luft und
vom boden aus abgeschossen werden mit
diesem system kann sich die kleine form
angriffen durch flugzeuge hubschrauber
oder marschflugkörper schützen ebenfalls
auf der liste maas zwei raketenwerfer
jeweils zwölf raketen werden von einem
kettenfahrzeug abgeschossen auf eine
distanz von bis zu 85 kilometern
außerdem sagt scholz der ukraine ein
hochmodernes ortung sra dazu dass
feindliche haubitzen mörser und raketen
artillerie
aufkläre waffen die die ukraine zuletzt
immer lauter als unterstützung des
westens eingefordert hatte um sich gegen
den russischen vormarsch im donbass zu
stemmen zum stand der kämpfe dort eine
grid oster
die bilder des russischen
verteidigungsministeriums sollen die
ganze wucht der angriffe zeigen das
militär hat seine kräfte mittlerweile
massiv gebündelt ihr ziel der dornbach
bilder aus sehr wie er o ton jetzt zu 70
prozent soll die strategisch wichtige
stadt bereits unter russischer kontrolle
sein in zwei bis drei tagen so schätzt
der gouverneur heute morgen werden die
russen die stadt in der region lohans
vollständig kontrollieren
zehntausende sind geflüchtet fast alle
wohngebäude zerbombt die regionen lohans
kundtun jetzt bilden zusammen den don
was das wahrscheinlich nächste ziel nach
sehr wie er oder jetzt die
zwillingsstadt lisicki damit hätten die
russen ganz lohans unter kontrolle ein
wesentliches ziel putins
der feind greift unser land mit
allergrößter aggression an das hauptziel
der besatzer ist es dann jetzt und
lohans zu erobern und einen landkorridor
zur besetzten krim halbinsel zu schaffen
damit soll der zugang zur ukraine zum
nordwestlichen schwarzen meer blockiert
werden
die meisten menschen sind raus aus
lessings die die geblieben sind
schwanken zwischen angst und
fassungslosigkeit
es ist unfassbar wir leben im 21
jahrhundert haben einen krieg und
sprechen doch die gleiche sprache
militärische beobachter gehen davon aus
dass die russischen truppen zivile
donetsk und lässig als vorposten nutzen
wollen um weiter in den westen in die
region bonn jetzt vorzudringen der krieg
wird wohl monatelang weiter toben
ich möchte nur frieden ich möchte dass
sie uns in ruhe lassen
dieser wunsch wird wohl noch eine ganze
weile nicht in erfüllung gehen
johannes hano berichtet für uns aus der
ukraine und ist derzeit in rudis am
johannes es gibt experten die halten die
einnahme des donners nur noch für eine
frage kurzer zeit die ukraine gibt aber
ja noch nicht auf wie stellt sich die
lage aus deiner sicht dar
also offiziell gibt es noch keine
stellungnahme dass man sich zurückziehen
wird aber hinter vorgehaltener hand ist
völlig klar die meisten leute sprechen
davon dass der don was wohl verloren ist
jetzt wird auch schon darüber spekuliert
dass es einen taktischen rückzug
ukrainische einheiten geben wird um sie
für eine einkesselung zu schützen die
nämlich die totale vernichtung dieser
einheiten bedeuten würde der ukrainische
präsident selensky hat davon gesprochen
dass ihnen schlicht und einfach die
waffen fehlen um diesen krieg gewinnen
zu können und es gibt tatsächlich die
vermutung hier dass diese waffen so
zögerlich geliefert werden um vladimir
putin die eroberung des dollars zu
ermöglichen wo im gegenzug dafür eine
waffenruhe zu bekommen die aber nicht
kommen wird sei es man die ukraine fest
überzeugt nun hat deutschland
angekündigt waffen zu liefern weitere
waffen auch schwere waffen zu liefern
auch die usa wollen neue moderne waffen
für die an die ukraine liefern darunter
mehrfach raketenwerfer mit und 80
kilometer reichweite kann das alles am
ende dann entscheidend sein
also das ist auf jeden fall ein
unterschied machen kann es völlig klar
wenn man sich die reaktion des kreml auf
diese ankündigung anschaut da hat man
davon gesprochen dass eine solche
lieferung eine eskalation bedeuten würde
aber fakt ist die ukraine ist auf diese
verhalten luftabwehrsysteme angewiesen
wir haben hier eben gerade wieder luft
einnahmen gehabt die ganze ukraine liegt
unter luftalarm es gab vor wenigen
minuten mehrere einschläge bei die wie
die großen die russischen truppen legen
ganze städte permanent unter feuer und
strategisch wichtige punkte und ein
solches abwehrsystem würde enorm dabei
helfen die steht zu schützen was man
hier aber sieht ist das ist eine große
ankündigung ist dass es viel angekündigt
wird viel versprochen wird aber de facto
nichts wirklich ankommt und sollte es
irgendwann mal ein paar monaten ankommen
dann könnte es eigentlich schon zu spät
sein danke johannes hano nach odessa
die frage der wirksamkeit der
waffenlieferungen darum wird sich unser
heute-journal update intensiver kümmern
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
anderen wichtigen nachrichten des tages
gundula gause der verteidigungsausschuss
des bundestages hat am abend den
wirtschaftsplan für das sogenannte
sondervermögen der bundeswehr gebilligt
vorbehalte der union konnten offenbar
ausgeräumt werden ein weiterer
verwendungszweck stand zur forschung
fest verteidigungsminister in lambrecht
hat entschieden für mehr als fünf
milliarden euro 60 schwere
transporthubschrauber vom typ
ch-47 chinook vom us-hersteller boeing
anzuschaffen die bundeswehr wartet seit
jahren auf das zwischenzeitlich
gestoppte projekt
ungarn hat erneut das jüngste eu
sanktionspaket mit dem geplanten
öl-embargo gegen russland blockiert
eu-diplomaten zufolge weigerte sich das
land heute bei den detail verhandlungen
sanktionen gegen den russischen
patriarchen kirill zuzustimmen die
staats und regierungschefs der eu hatten
sich am montag nach zähem ringen auf ein
sechstes aktionspaket gegen russland
geeinigt nun könnte die blockade ungarns
dem beschluss doch noch kippen
die bundesregierung will mit
gewerkschaften und arbeitgebern über
gemeinsame maßnahmen gegen die hohe
inflation beraten bundeskanzler scholz
hatte die sogenannte konzertierte aktion
im bundestag angekündigt es brauche eine
gezielte kraftanstrengung in einer ganz
außergewöhnlichen
situation wirtschaftsminister habeck
erklärte es gehe darum ein weiteres
anheizen der inflation durch hohe
lohnabschlüsse zu vermeiden die eu
kommission ist bereit polen fast 24
milliarden euro aus dem europäischen
corona vom auszuzahlen wegen des
jahrelangen streits über die polnischen
justizreformen hatte die eu die
fördergelder bislang blockiert nach
zugeständnissen von polnischer seite
gibt es nun offenbar eine einigung die
eu kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
morgen in warschau vorstellen will in
portugal breitet sich die omikron sub
variante b a5 weiter aus nach angaben
des nationalen gesundheitsinstituts
entfallen fast 87 prozent aller
neuinfektionen auf diese mutation die
sieben tage incidents hat sich seit
mitte april auf rund 1800 vervierfacht
trotz der hohen impfquote von 87 in
portugal stieg zuletzt auch die zahl der
hospitalisierungen und der todesfälle im
zusammenhang mit corona
ärzte haben vor dramatischen engpässen
bei der medizinischen versorgung von
kindern und jugendlichen in deutschland
gewarnt aufgrund erheblichen
personalmangels könne auf vielen kinder
intensivstationen ein drittel teilt
sogar die hälfte der betten nicht belegt
werden erklärten mediziner der funke
mediengruppe wegen infektionswellen im
herbst könne sich die lage noch
verschärfen
dass sich das prinzip vom wandel durch
handel als illusion erweist ist eine
bittere erkenntnis dieses jahres 20 22
putins angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
zeigt mit den wahren werden eben nicht
auch die werte exportiert chinas
staatspräsident wies den westen letzte
woche kühl darauf hin man habe seine
eigenen menschenrechte wolle das modell
anderer länder keinesfalls kopieren
vorausgegangen waren berichte und fotos
von brutalen menschenrechtsverletzungen
an den uiguren der muslimischen
minderheit im land die deutsche
regierung will nun handfeste
konsequenzen ziehen über protestnoten
hinaus andreas kienast aus berlin
dass frau sich frei ist und in berlin
dass sie berichten kann über das lager
haben chinesische behörden mit fast
allen mitteln zu verhindern versucht
aber frau weg berichtet über folter und
mord über schmerzen und wut über das so
genannte umerziehungslager in shenyang
man hat den frauen die haare kurz
geschoren sie mussten uniformen tragen
und immer wieder zum verhör
aus dem verhörraum habe ich grausame
schreie gehört ich bin zeugen von
vergewaltigungen geworden nichts von dem
was ich dort erlebt habe kann ich jemals
wieder vergessen
frau sie dick wird ihre heimat nie
wieder sehen wie ihre familie die man
für sie bestrafte sie ihren mann den man
zur scheidung zwang jetzt kann sie
berichten aber hört jemand zu dass die
kleinere kuchen delegation an diesem
nachmittag ins auswärtige amt darf ist
ein großer tag und folge einer großen
enthüllung nach den tausenden dokumenten
den die gesehenen fotos die seit letzter
woche als ich in gang police files die
welt erschüttern stellt die
bundesregierung fragen das ist nichts wo
man drüber hinweggehen kann und das ist
auch nichts worüber man schweigen kann
so unwiderlegbar ist jetzt was china
hunderttausend figuren an tut das mit
deutschland nun auch das land reagiert
das wirtschaftlich am engsten mit china
verflochten ist zum ersten mal streicht
die bundesregierung einem unternehmen
staatsgarantien weil es in jin young
produziert volkswagen
das ist natürlich volkswagen
freigestellt weiter zu investieren bzw
wirklich woanders hin zu stellen aber
das finde ich sachgemäß wir können nicht
mit der garantie des steuerzahlers in
regionen wir wissen dass zwangsarbeit
und unterdrückung herrscht auch nach
wirtschaftlichen prosperität schützen
jahre jahrzehnte hat nicht nur die
bundesregierung auf wandel durch handel
gesetzt sondern auch die industrie
volkswagen sieht sich bis heute als
exporteur von deutschen autos und von
europäischen werten
handel und kommunikation und aktivitäten
in den anderen ländern führen dazu dass
wir vielleicht eine chance haben die
anderen länder in diese richtung zu
bewegen dass sich politisch und
insbesondere mit blick auf
menschenrechtsfragen durch unseren
handel mit china etwas verbessert davon
dürfen wir nicht mehr ausgehen frau sie
war lehrerin ging young sie hatte sich
als beamten eigentlich sicher gefühlt
aber selbst ich wurde auf anordnung der
chinesischen regierung
zwangssterilisiert man hat mir die
gebärmutter entfernt
frau zach hat viel geopfert um aussagen
zu können und lange gewartet bis man
hier zu hören im bundestag wird sie
morgen berichten
mehr zu diesem thema im ausland schon
mal unser china korrespondent ulf röller
berichtet über die systematische
unterdrückung der uiguren hat opfer und
fluchthelfer getroffen gleich hier im
anschluss und nur noch mal nachrichten
top-thema an der frankfurter börse war
die razzia bei der fondstochter der
deutschen bank dws wegen des verdachts
auf anlagebetrug bei grünen
finanzprodukten der vorwurf greenwashing
also etikettenschwindel bei den angaben
zur nachhaltigkeit von geldanlagen
valerie haller wie klar sind denn
eigentlich diese vorgaben in sachen
nachhaltigkeit ja das ist genau das
problem dass es noch immer keine
verbindlichen regeln und standards gibt
was grün was nachhaltig überhaupt
bedeutet oft dass die definition von
ethischen und ökologischen
geldanlagen einfach sehr sehr schwammig
die dws wird verdächtigt produkte
womöglich als grüner ausgewiesen zu
haben als sie es tatsächlich waren und
dabei stützte sich die dws auf esg
kriterien die für nachhaltigkeit stehen
und mit dem esg label schmücken banken
und finanzdienstleister ihrer
nachhaltigen finanzprodukten gerne die
abkürzung steht für die englischen
begriffe umwelt soziales und gute
unternehmensführung laut
staatsanwaltschaft spielten esg aspekte
aber nur bei einer minderheit der dws
investments eine rolle rund 50 ermittler
von staatsanwaltschaft
und finanzaufsicht durchsuchten die
geschäftsräume der deutschen bank und
ihrer tochter dws nur wenige stunden
nach der razzia kündigt dws chef hermann
seinen rücktritt an an der börse kommt
die razzia gar nicht gut an die aktien
der dws verlieren massiv die deutsche
bank hat sich das thema nachhaltigkeit
groß auf die fahnen geschrieben
ausgerechnet in diesem bereich
glaubwürdigkeit zu verlieren trifft die
bank an einer empfindlichen stelle aber
auch die finanzindustrie insgesamt die
gerade die grüne welle sehr sehr gerne
reitet außerdem zeigt der fall dws das
greenwashing kein kavaliersdelikt ist
vielen dank valerie für diese
information
kroatien wird ab kommendem jahr den euro
einführen können die eu-kommission sieht
die voraussetzungen erfüllt weniger als
ein jahrzehnt nach dem eu-beitritt
kroatiens zustimmen müssen noch alle
mitgliedsstaaten im eu rat davon wird
ausgegangen zuletzt war 2015 litauen als
neun zehntes mitglied in den euro raum
aufgenommen worden eine meldung vom
tennis alexander zverev die deutsche
nummer eins wird im halbfinale der
french open gegen rafael nadal antreten
zverev hatte im viertelfinale den
spanischen senkrechtstarter carlos
alcaraz besiegt und spaniens als da
nadal novak djokovic
gleich zur queen hier die gewinnzahlen
vom lotto am mittwoch sie lauten ohne
gewähr 24 9
32 42 48 superzahl 9 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zf
text auf seite 55 7 in london und im
gesamten vereinigten königreich bereitet
man sich mit großer leidenschaft auf das
70 thronjubiläum der queen vor zum
auftakt der viertägigen feierlichkeiten
soll morgen die traditionelle
militärparade am buckingham palast
stattfinden zudem ist unter anderem ein
großer festumzug mit zehntausenden
darstellern aus allen landesteilen
geplant seit
1952 ist elisabeth die zweite
staatsoberhauptes einigten königreichs
und damit die dienstälteste monarchen
der welt und sie kommt hoffentlich gut
durch die nächsten tage ab 0.45 übrigens
bei uns im zdf die lange nacht zum
thronjubiläum
mit gleich sechs dokumentationen alle
auch in der mediathek den auftakt macht
diana zimmermann mit ihrem blick auf den
zustand des königreichs und direkt davor
um 0.30 ist hier wieder zeit für unser
heute-journal update mit nacktem ihren
morgen begrüßt sie an dieser stelle
marietta slomka
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend richtig heiß ist es im moment im
mittelmeer umfeld da haben wir
temperaturen vom süden spaniens
frankreichs bis hinüber ins östliche
mittelmeer zwischen 30 und 40 45 grad an
der nordspitze afrikas bei uns gibt es
morgen noch temperaturen um die 20 grad
und dieses zwischenhoch sorgt auch für
freundliches wetter ab freitag dann
kommt aber von dieser schwülen luft auch
bei uns etwas an und damit stehen uns
unwetter bevor in der nacht da bilden
sich in den frühstunden in schleswig
holstein neue schauer der gewittriger
regen südlich der donau der klingt
langsam ab dazwischen ist es oft klar
bei örtlichem nebel sinken die
temperaturen auf 3 10 bis 3 grad große
unterschiede gibt es auch am tag da geht
es im süden hinauf auf 22 bis 27 grad im
norden gibt es 15 bis 21 grad dafür
bekommt der norden aber am morgen auch
mal wieder mehr sonne ab nur im
küstenumfeld haben wir noch schauer bei
einem stark böigen wind nachmittags dann
im südlichen alpenvorland auch noch mal
kurze schauer oder gewitter sonst große
wolkenlücken morgen am freitag und am
samstag geht es im norden auch mit
freundlichem wetter bei angenehmen
temperaturen weiter aber im südwesten
und auch in der mitte und im südwesten
am samstag kommt diese luft bis 30 grad
an und da sind dann eben auch heftige
gewitter mit starkregen und sturmböen
möglich und auch über die
pfingstfeiertage bleibt die gefahr von
unwettern bestehen mehr zu den gewittern
morgen hier schalten sie gerne ein